Welcome back everyone this is my video about
andrew garfield coming back in the future
for more spider-man movies as his version of the
amazing spider-man toby maguire is also reportedly
coming back again to along with more of the core
characters from their original movies but i'll
start with the andrew garfield stuff because he
is the first one to actually speak openly about
coming back again after spider-man no way home so
if you're new to the channel be sure to subscribe
to get all the videos there will be a lot more
spider-man multiverse crossover in the morbius
movie later this year along with a lot more tobey
maguire andrew garfield easter eggs as we've seen
in all the trailers but careful for spoilers for
spider-man no way home if you haven't seen it yet
just because we have to talk about everything that
happened during the movie with toby mcguire and
andrew garfield's characters if you've seen people
talking about andrew garfield coming back for more
marvel movies more spider-man movies this is the
clip that they're referring to this is him talking
about actually coming back to entertainment
tonight could you would you do it again would
you put the suit on if given the opportunity i
mean i you know never say never i mean it's such
it's it's a character that's always gonna be
so meaningful to me and so beautiful to me and
again it comes back to service you know i think
if there's a way because that's what's that's
what that character is all about he's all about
serving the greater good and serving his fellow
fellow people his fellow you know serving
humanity and all life you know so if there's a way
for me to continue to add to the legacy
of that character in a way that feels
like it's of service to an audience of service to
the themes of you know the themes that stan lee
kind of uh you know injected that character with
i'm open of course i'm very very open so what
he's saying in that interview is he's trying not
to give away too much about the plans sony and
marvel have made like he's kind of tongue-in-cheek
kind of smiling about like well you know can't say
too much but he says as long as the movies they
bring him back for are meaningful stories and
do service to the true essence of spider-man as
laid out by stan lee like he literally references
making sure that his future cameos and spider-man
movies would stay true to the way stan lee
wrote the spider-man character that yes of course
he would come back like he's always open to coming
back there's about as much as he could say
without breaking any kind of confidentiality
agreement with marvel and sony but of course they
talked about them coming back in a bigger way
when they signed them to contracts for spider-man
no way home like do you want to come back for this
and they all said yes after they got so excited
about the way they wrote their characters and
what was going on with them in the movie then
right after that that's when sony and marvel
say okay how about more would you be interested
in coming back for more and that all happened a
long time ago like they had both officially signed
their contracts to come back for spider-man no way
home before december of 2019 so they were actually
fully on board with the movie a long long time ago
i know a lot of you are asking what would the
story be for andrew garfield spider-man going
forward i've done a couple of spider-man no way
home deleted scenes videos for the post-credits
scenes that they had planned to do for toby
mcguire and andrew garfield's versions of
spider-man and what was going to happen is that
they were going to just use those credit scenes
to tease what would be happening with their
characters next after they went back to their
universes it sounds like they decided not to use
those because they just wanted to save that story
like say whatever they would be doing next for the
next times that they appeared in new movies but
then bringing andrew garfield and toby maguire
on the other side of this back for more movies
as their spider-man after this just answers
a lot of questions about that confusing soup
of easter eggs in the morbius trailer with
all three different versions of spider-man
the tobey maguire spider-man suit with the
tom holland mysterio murder plot points the
tom holland mcu looking version of michael
keaton's vulture the tobey maguire version of
the daily bugle but with easter eggs for andrew
garfield's amazing spider-man villains on it
the andrew garfield's amazing spider-man version
of ozcorp and the tom hardy venom name drop at the
end of the trailer it's like sony said give me
references and scenes from every single version
of spider-man mix it in a bowl and we'll call it
a movie i also did a separate morbius video about
all the morbius easter eggs in amazing spider-man
2. if you don't remember sony was originally
intending on introducing a version of morbius
in the andrew garfield era of spider-man movies
there was also another version of venom that they
had planned on introducing during his amazing
spider-man 3 movie i know a lot of people have
been talking about them doing amazing spider-man
3 now i will address that but before andrew
garfield and toby maguire had been confirmed
in spider-man no way home you probably saw a bunch
of funny theories about the morbius trailer with
all these confusing easter eggs like people
thought that sony was just drunk at the wheel
and throwing a bunch of easter eggs at the movie
without intending on having any of them make sense
but now that andrew garfield and toby maguire are
confirmed back and coming back for more future
movies after this in spider-man no way home has
canonized all their movies and the tom hardy venom
movies to this larger marvel cinematic multiverse
because of that they don't have to change any of
these combo easter eggs in the morbius movie they
can just say this earth that morbius comes from
is yet another universe where their version of
spider-man looks like this but their oscorp looks
like the andrew garfield version and they have
a bunch of amazing spider-man andrew garfield
villains that tobey maguire never faced in his
movies like rhino and black cat but they can also
use a morbius post-credit scene to say cross him
over with mcu tom hall and spider-man like they
did with tom hardy's version of venom as to imply
that we might see him in the mcu at some point
like a crossover with the new mahershala ali blade
character if you don't remember the first wesley
snipes blade movie they also had a morbius post
credit scene and that way back in the 90s that's
how long ago they were planning on doing a morbius
blade crossover in my morbius trailer video i did
a little while ago jared leto even directly
references a larger spider-man multiverse and
implies there's this huge connection with
spider-man no way home the film version of
morbius that we're bringing to you now he's also
a part of a much larger universe if you've seen
the last spider-man no way home trailer you know
the multiverse has officially opened and there's
all kinds of opportunities for villains to meet up
thrive and maybe even nurture their more sinister
intense that's all i'm gonna say for right now
so there's just a lot of opportunities for andrew
garfield and toby maguire to come back because
of all these other sony movies that they're doing
so on the marvel mcu side of things the movies
that andrew garfield would most likely be coming
back for just based on the way that he's talking
about the character coming back would be like
a big secret wars avengers movie like there are
rumors now that marvel is legit pushing for secret
wars as the next avengers movie way faster than i
ever thought that they would they're doing so many
multiverse characters now between the spider-man
versions in spider-man no way home and the reports
about all the x-men fox characters having cameo
scenes and doctor strange multiverse of madness
clearly they're building towards a secret war
style giant multiverse movie but on the sony
side of things separately they have a billion
different spider-man spin-off movies they're
making like venom 3 morbius sequels there's a
craven the hunter movie they're making with aaron
taylor johnson mcu quicksilver is going to play
sony's craven you didn't see that coming there
are also a lot of craven the hunter easter eggs in
the morbius movie that we'll see but they haven't
appeared in the trailers yet there's also a black
cat movie in a spider woman movie that sony is
making too and they want as much spider-man in
those movies as they can spare but tom holland
has been very clear on his side of things that he
doesn't want to do 30 more spider-man movies so
the easy solution now that they have established
multiverse versions of spider-man is that during
some of these upcoming sony driven spider-man
spin-offs the version of spider-man that they
reference they lean on can be andrew garfield and
toby maguire's versions of spider-man eventually
they'll also introduce a live-action miles morales
so he'll turn into another multiverse crossover
spider-man too so eventually you just have a bunch
of different versions of spider-man you can pick
from when you do a new spider-man spin-off movie
and you want a version of spider-man in it and
speaking more about miles morales even though tom
holland said he also wanted his mcu spider-man
to be a mentor to a version of miles morales
someday and they've already introduced an mcu
miles morales and spider-man homecoming they can
also use andrew garfield's spider-man in another
mentorship type role there was another clip of
andrew garfield talking about spider-man no way
home and his relationship with mcu spider-man
and it makes me think that he's also waiting
for more of a similar mentorship opportunity in
a future movie to come back suddenly gets broken
open and these three guys who maybe felt very
lonely in the universe before suddenly are aware
that they're never alone they never have been
alone and actually there is a brotherhood out
there and god knows how many more spider-man
peter parkers there are out there to share
in that support group with because that's what
it felt i decided to feel like a kind of like
strange peter parker spider-man support group
like a kind of you know like a 12-step program
for spider-man and peter parker's and
and the beauty of that like the beauty of
like what the writer's craft did and what we all
crafted together of trying to you know to to save
our younger brother from you know the
paths that we have tried i found that
deeply moving mentorship like the theme
of mentorship and and how these two people
across the universe were the only ones that could
really fully understand what this young man was
going through and we were just there to kind of
support and have a lot of fun and it was so much
fun i can't belie i still can't believe it it
happened so clearly they're building a spider-man
multiverse support group like what do you call
this giant group of spiderverse characters
live-action spider-verse support group let me
know in the comments though which marvel movies
and which sony movies do you want to see andrew
garfield and toby maguire come back for when
andrew garfield comes back what they'll probably
do is just continue to tell the story of his
spider-man going forward in the timeline maybe do
more flashbacks across multiple movies every time
he does come back and in some of those movies
he'll just be more of a main character the same
way that marvel is done for the hulk across the
avengers movies or thor ragnarok i will do more
andrew garfield and toby mcguire spider-man videos
if we get more clues about them coming back i'm
also working on a new avengers 5 video that should
post tomorrow we found out about what most of the
new team's roster is going to be and what some of
their new costumes will look like it's pretty cool
make sure you have alerts enabled for my
channel so you don't miss that everyone click
here to see tom hall and spider-man symbiote
suit and more spider-man no way home deleted
scenes and click here for that brand new thor
love and thunder first look at rune king thor
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!